[Music]
in celebrity rumor news
so oh I think I know what it is no again
Kylie happy in her [ __ ] body cardio
that's been circulating on Instagram
submitted by China number one oh it's
agent rumors I don't think so China [ __ ]
no man number one not copying I rather
have Madagascar number one before China
believe my favorite CGI movie was we
know what happens in China
no man is getting why oh why Madagascar
cuz they got marsupial that's lucky the
[ __ ] lemur dude zoboomafoo yeah I
mean they got cool animals you know top
the show oh yeah Sabu I forgot about
that job once China gets their [ __ ]
together though then I'll be like ah you
know before China all right rumors have
sparked about the hot asian bodyguard
that looks like Kylie Jenner's newborn
girl yo straight up though they look
exactly alike
that was pretty good lucky this
[ __ ] sexy you know you know
what uh this guy walls getting my hair
cut me get his name I forgot to Tim
Chung when I was getting when I was
getting my hair cut my Barber's like I
cut his hair boy yeah he keeps his hair
cut Vince yeah I know he's that oh that
guy may he come here all the time and
I'm all like are you sure yeah man he's
a cop
yeah don't don't cops they do the
[ __ ] security afterwards right and
I'm like oh he just like comes in he's
like hey let me get the joke
ya know I know his name cuz I'm sick of
people asking if we're twins like I'm so
annoying
so he's Korean Chung Chung is Korean
right or any Chinese it's J is doing out
here [ __ ] me or Chinese with the
spelling you never ate ung well my
barber has says is that he does not come
around oh no cuz he got the BC oh yeah
damn getting busy
yeah Kylie Jenner I will say this though
that is a [ __ ] attractive man yeah I
bet you he doesn't have psoriasis so
this is stormy right stormy Chung why
does it look like a Cambodian baby but
yeah they all come out like that funny
thing is a lot of babies look me like
like Asian cuz they don't have a epic a
pic fold you feel like swoosh togethers
dude knows but no but also there is
there is merit to this argument yeah
yeah see like people broke it down but a
lot of babies look similar in the very
beginning true I don't know she even has
a thing I'm like the [ __ ] DNA test
that [ __ ] ya know the outer corners of
her eyes and his eyes
somebody get 23andme well I heard that
um
Travis Scott's mom wants a paternity
test now after this [ __ ] went viral Oh
crazy that's what I heard you know her
ex Tyga mm-hmm so initially he was
saying like that's my baby
well that would make sense to keynesian
yeah he's part but no more yeah and then
after he was like that's Tim's baby he
said that yes I guess is that how you
good said that what Tiger saying that he
thinks that he's the baby daddy
this [ __ ] here's a Karl your
bottle wasn't lying yeah model I never
seen that picture before
cop model he's a cop he's all like
freeze and then all the games is like
damn si you're [ __ ] fine he knows good
lucky taking selfies I don't know any
manatee at the LAPD [ __ ] back within
you oh yeah LAPD bathroom selfies LAPD
bad news of his damn Instagram following
went crazy like the pass know exactly
where he's at because that shit's right
next to morongo casino on the way to
Palm Springs oh yeah the spitting yeah
that's not true yes everyone's like yeah
that storm he's dead Rick like Rick saw
the pictures he's like he's like he's
barely tolerant Kylie that's not a
bodyguard that is a [ __ ] friend right
there well because they're saying that
she hand selected him and that none of
her other bodyguards are young like you
wait so he's not tall he looks tall him
in the pictures this say this is Ben
that's a I'm Kylie he's like he's like
here in the pictures was really quite
cold on let me get this right quick
is Kylie the model want how many model
ones are there Kylie is the one no she's
the one that did like crazy surgery
where she doesn't even look like herself
and she's the youngest one the youngest
one but I don't condone home-wrecking
but Thank You Kylie for putting Asian
guys on the [ __ ] map
I think everyone's gonna hype about that
okay she does even look like herself
anymore no she look good though way
better
have you seen the memes of like when she
was really young and I think they were
at an award show and then they zoom in
on the family but obviously Kim is the
center of attention so she stands up and
exhume it and then Kylie and who's at
Kendall Kendall are sitting down and
Kylie's just like me she has like her
weird pointy nose and her little paper
lip should be brilliant I know half of
her face was like this on Twitter they
were like someone's like yo that baby
does not look like Kylie and then
someone's like [ __ ] Kylie don't look
yo we might be [ __ ] up that just might
look like regular car original face all
right there the babies really looks like
a hunch doll true maybe that's when I do
agree with plastic surgery
well her butt looks really fresh and she
might have heels on right that's ooh
oh yeah let me see Kylie before after
I need that dude up [ __ ] Wow with a
single cup i boned that [ __ ] and [ __ ]
implants seeds as soon as possible I
will say this into the guy or the girl
Oh bunk no because you know you just won
the lotto buddy hell yeah [ __ ] baby
with Kylie no I think they're really
smart they might have a prenup
maybe I mean they got so much money
Kylie and Chelsea married though so
there's no peanut oh I'm pretty sure
there's some sort of contract that young
girl though like I didn't I didn't
because I don't really follow like the
Kardashians [ __ ] but when I saw the
before she really didn't have any lips
like she could she could only blow half
a kiss like that's how [ __ ] her upper
lip was in a big deal but it's like that
like just like that it was yeah it's
like they had my teeth are wet now oh
there yeah no that's still the very cute
picture of her yeah like who it's like
who is that girl on the [ __ ] right
you don't even shoot yet boobs true
dirty that's her name younger young yes
oh I think like this one yep and that's
like totally different people she's
still cute on the left though yeah she's
not ugly it was nothing wrong with her
before man she's a cute girl she's not
ugly yeah I bet you in person just this
comparison wine I will say she's like
the one that started off all these
chicks getting those lips [ __ ] yeah yeah
I mean she was the one that got it she
definitely made it popular the wig stuff
I mean people been wearing wigs though
they have been but she made it way more
popular with the all pink one and all
blue one and the stuff like that that
was her [ __ ] Oh
because I thought it was just like
Instagram girl [ __ ] Lil Kim everyday
wearing wigs that Kylie infiltrated
white girls Mexican girls to wear wigs
of me I say there's no black girls been
doing that [ __ ] son lace front wigs
[ __ ] fighters I mean that I think
that's a lot the main issue with Kylie
and them is they're like she's making
all these um these changes to look like
[ __ ] that's traditional like like a
black girl thing exactly now people are
like looking at her like oh my god she's
amazing you look beautiful and she's
like [ __ ] out of here black women been
having that [ __ ] hold all that family
except for Kendall I like applauded
Kendall for keeping it natural yeah yeah
I'm deciding Kendall Jenner was she the
[ __ ] beautiful she's [ __ ]
beautiful though even though she was a
Jenna I was like what the [ __ ] is his
[ __ ] amazing looking human being she
looks like a piece of art yeah she's
beautiful no for when she was young oh
the [ __ ] happened I think it's the
makeup yeah I feel like she matured her
in Emily Ratajkowski oh that's a pretty
lady they're connected by the mother
right and the Kardashians it's all
connected by the mom yeah Emily
Ratajkowski is so pretty
I feel guilty for you trying to
masturbate to her you know I mean she's
like a piece of art and then Booth's
Jenner came into their life and then now
it's what does Caitlyn Caitlyn Jenner
yeah yeah yeah okay we know a lot yeah
that's interesting
oh you know I never used to watch the
Kardashian show i am i i watched i watch
here and there there was one time me my
boy it was like it was like we were
hungover one night or one morning and I
he had crashed and we woke up it was
like we didn't hurt none of the we
didn't open the windows and turning
lights on and like cardiac like
Kardashian was on and we just watched
all day okay quick we just watch it is
sexuality we just watched the old days
[ __ ] hungover in the dark watching
the Kardashians yeah it's like I didn't
even know that they had like their own
like reality show you know I mean and
that's how they gained their fame
originally basically isn't that yeah
it's pretty interesting originally
16m is the one that made everyone rayjet
has a huge dick it's a big dick yeah
yeah that thing was ridiculous no it's
free it's pre insane yeah it's
entertaining like eight nine ten inches
it looks like a baby's arm holding an
apple it's like this yes a big big yeah
a little longer not that's that's that
is oh this one looks like he weighs like
130 but if you cut his dick off maybe
that one's happy yep that's what doesn't
look you know the most shocking part of
that thing when I saw it I was like yeah
of course skinny guy yeah at that point
anything you see Kim Kardashian may have
a carne asada burrito yeah you see you
see him like like he's hitting it from
the back of bed and then like she's
giving him head for a bit and then um
they do that they do the the flat down
from the back yeah froggy style it's
known as you know like you know like
when she's on her stomach and then you
just got you're going in from behind
yeah yeah that's a good one that's my
favorite it's called froggy stone oh
I've never heard that I've heard it's
called I used to call it the lazy doggy
because you're just laying in the back
but people online told me it's also
called the prone bone have no idea why
prone gone or the speed bump I like the
speed I could see a speed bump yeah it's
just like well yeah but he recorded the
wrong angles it's just can face it for
the whole time half the time I described
through it I'm like and this fool is
just like CID they're just biting his
lip oh I know that's the worst he could
you turn the camera on himself his
body's gonna watch himself [ __ ] that's
why yeah I know people say that he gave
her the video and that she leaked it
like she leaked it so then well I don't
believe that because just recently they
there was a voicemail that leaked that
from a long time ago where she left it
on his [ __ ] after the the stuff started
leaking and she's like I can't believe
you would do this you are a horrible
person
call me back right now then she's like
no you know what don't even call me back
I can't believe you I never want to talk
to
and this is like this like when the sex
tape was dropping oh really no true cuz
you could have recorded it like a year
to later bro
no porno was so fun back in there oh
yeah sexy asian dude yeah so she
followed Paris Hilton's footsteps very
well she does look like she's man she
does look mix she's that's definitely
his kid baby yeah he's [ __ ] maybe
they'll do like OJ and Khloe and just
never admit it that probably you know
I'm saying a lot of there's like a rumor
that OJ Simpson is Khloe Kardashian's
dead yeah and that's no way yeah yes she
doesn't really look like the other ones
at all yeah yeah well she looks black
which one's Khloe the one that doesn't
look like she's like the tall like she's
like kind of taller the older one I had
the kids first no she looks like Kim
Kourtney yeah really always quoted the
more big boom yeah she just had a baby
recently she's the one that her baby I
look like Oh Jay Simpson while she was
in labor she fell okay forehead bone
yams in might be it I don't know who
knows
[Music]